les du sud
la région ouest plus précisément
la plus sauvage la moins peuplée de
nouvelle zélande
600 km de côtes
vingt-trois mille kilomètres carrés pour
à peine plus de 30 mille âmes
un habitant kilomètres carrés
un territoire vierge
un désert démographique
cet endroit est perdu il n'y a aucune
route rien très peu de gens mais c'est
vraiment sauvage
[Musique]
c'est tough le pilote qui le premier a
évoqué son ami robert lang
un homme et une famille devenus des
légendes locales
vous connaissez depuis longtemps c'est
robert lang et doit faire 25 peut-être
trente ans ça fait longtemps qu'il vit
là bas je les ai rencontrés par hasard
comme ça dans la forêt il n'est jamais
parti c'est un sacré personnage ce gars
là vous allez l'adorer
il n'y a aucun autre moyen pour se
rendre chez lui je veux dire autrement
qu'en hélicoptère s'il faut attendre que
tous les fleuves et les rivières
décembre pour les traversées et croyez
moi c'est un voyage périlleux
[Musique]
une heure de vol contre trois ou quatre
jours de marche à travers la forêt
voilà le tarif pour qui veut rejoindre
la gorge rivaux
et rencontrer le maître des lieux
[Musique]
allez un petit dernier ce sera bon
de lui
c'est l'heure du thé je ramasse un peu
de bois et je le ramène à la maison
on va balancer tout ça au feu et
s'assurer que la théière
boyer j'en ai partout je stocke aussi
ici du bois
l'histoire de robert lang et de la gorge
river commence comme un coup de foudre
étudiant en médecine à la fin des années
70 le jeune homme s'ennuie sur les bancs
de la faculté il veut donner un sens à
sa vie et décide de prendre la route à
pied
je me suis mis à voyager parce que je
cherchais un endroit où vivre je ne
voyageais pas juste pour avoir du pays
je voulais rendre loin du monde des
routes dans la nature la plus sauvage
quand je suis arrivé il n'y avait pas
âme qui vive
j'ai traversé la rivière et j'ai su que
c'était là et j'ai passé ma première
nuit dans cette cabane c'était le 28
novembre 1980
la forêt la rivière la mer de tasman
vont lui offrir de quoi se nourrir
robert va restaurer la vieille
vinci seul pendant une dizaine d'années
catherine une biologiste venus faire des
recherches dans la région croiser le
chemin du jeune homme
il tombe amoureux elle décide de rester
le couple va élever deux enfants la
gorge river parti aujourd'hui vivre leur
vie d'adulte
[Musique]
je commence toujours par la collecte du
bois c'est le premier boulot de la
journée
je fais un peu avant d'aller pêcher en
attendant que la marée descendante
ça me permet d'avaler un tout chaud
avant de partir
et ça chauffe la maison j'aimais ma
balle on regarde et
on peut prendre des douches en dc
l'eau courante elle vient d'une cascade
dans la colline qui est derrière
quand je suis arrivé je me contentais de
collecter de l'eau qui tombait sur le
toit mais ça ne suffisait pas s'il ne
pleuvait pas pendant une semaine ou deux
par exemple alors je me suis directement
accordée la semaine
avec le temps
la famille longue à apprivoiser les
lieux
mais vivre au bout du monde loin des
sommes à 1 pris
à la gorge river il est question de
survie au quotidien
chaque matin robert parent ainsi en
quête de nourriture
mais j'ai mal là dedans
c'est une bonne pêche oui oui
je vais probablement relâcher la plupart
je n'en garde que très peu de temps
dans la nasse une prise de premier choix
je les à pattes avec de la viande de
cerf elle adore des anguilles géante de
nouvelle zélande
elles sont considérées comme un mets
très délicats vous savez
ils encerclent dont les avions d'air
nouvelle zélande
ils les fume et il les propose en
première classe
je vais laisser partir celle là
ouais pourquoi voulez vous lâcher parce
que je ne vais pas tout les manger il y
en a assez c'est une espèce de plus en
plus en danger je ne garde jamais les
plus grosses ce sont les maires
reproductrices
je vais garder celle là en revanche
[Musique]
elle est prête à passer au fumoir ce
sera bon cet après midi
e
[Musique]
décollez ça c'est bon c'est vraiment une
bonne journée de pêche ils sont très
goûteux
c'est un magnifique poisson argenté
1 2 3 4 5 6 je dois en avoir une dizaine
là on en a pour trois ou quatre génisses
attraper du poisson c'est le meilleur
moyen de survivre ici on mange pas moral
de protéines a pas celle des quelques
légumes qu'on cultive
alors voilà le meilleur moyen d'avoir
des protéines pour toute la famille
beaucoup de poisson ici
peut-être avez-vous besoin de plus
d'énergie ici que quelqu'un qui vit en
ville non
gelée pour son bus d'énergie qu'un
citadin
mais certaines personnes en ville font
du jogging tous les jours
d'autres cours le marathon des trucs
comme ça à la rue elles dépensent
beaucoup d'énergie
je ne cours pas le matin je fais juste
ce que j'ai à faire ici ça dépend des
jours mais oui ça peut ressembler à une
course d'endurance et puis d'autres
jours je suis à la maison je bricole on
a toujours de quoi s'occuper
les tâches sont ainsi partagé à la gorge
river
lorsque monsieur est à la pêche
madame jardine
le potager une pièce maîtresse de la vie
des longues
le domaine de kati
[Musique]
c'est assez compliqué de cultiver ici il
pleut beaucoup
la pluie détrempe la terre et emporte
tout
on y arrive on est quand même autonome
en légumes regardez là par exemple j'ai
déjà dit des haricots blancs et des
petits pois dans les herbes on mange
aussi ses petites fleurs jaunes en ce
moment
vous saviez tout ça en arrivant ici non
je ne savais même pas à quoi ressemblait
un plan de pommes de terre
qui vous a montré vous avez appris seul
nom c'est robert qui m'a tout montrer
j'ai eu des échecs au début mais il a
fallu apprendre vie
et pourquoi avez vous mis une cage sur
vos plans de carotte c'est pour les
empêcher de tout manger pour tenir les
opossums loin de mes carottes c'est ce
qu'ils mangent en premier ils en
raffolent
l'opossum un intrus au jardin d'éden
les problèmes de potagers de cathy
pourrait presque faire sourire
[Musique]
mais le podium est un sujet très sérieux
en nouvelle zélande
le pays est entré en guerre contre un
monstre une peste qui dévaste tout sur
son passage
la faune la flore les grands arbres
endémiques de l'île
robert pour défendre sa gorge river a
été contraint de se muer en chasseur
pour éradiquer ce petit marsupial
devenu l'ennemi public numéro un
malheureusement cette jolie petite
créature détruit une autre fournée
elle tue les oiseaux mangent leurs oeufs
cet animal a été introduit dans le pays
il ya 120 ans pour faire commerce de
sapho
vient d'australie
ils ont proliféré et aujourd'hui il y en
aurait 70 minutes
on ne contrôle plus rien et se
reproduisent plus vite qu'on ne les
chasse
on va descendre un peu par là et je vais
vous montrer les dégâts qu'ils font
vous voyez ces lectures ce sont des
marques de territoire
choisissent un arbre il est contre car
ils se l'approprient jusqu'à ce qu'il
meure 6 1
en seulement trois ans l'arbre
c'est dur à croire mais c'est parce
qu'ils mangent tout les jeunes jusque là
on est plus
c'est de la poudre de fleurs et du curry
ça les attire
c'est un poutou kawar c'est un de leur
arbre préféré
centaines de pièges comme celui là à
travers la forêt
je pourrais ne rien faire parce que je
ne veux pas les tuer j'aime les animaux
j'étais même végétarien quand je suis
arrivé ici
ça ne fait pas plaisir mais si personne
ne le fait tous ces arbres vont mourir
je ne veux pas voir ça
pour qu'il protège au mieux la forêt
primaire l'état lui a délivré un permis
de chasse
mais surtout le droit de faire commerce
de l'opossum
alors ce qu'il a une belle peau
qu'est ce que vous regardez là robert je
vérifie juste sa fourrure
si je ne garde pas la pole je prendrais
justin les poils
mais c'est la jolie et vous fait quoi
avec les peaux
s'ils ont une belle fourrure ont fait de
grands couvre lit avec une quarantaine
de peau des housses de coussins avec
seulement deux beaux comme
des manteaux en fourrure des écharpes ce
cadre
que ce soit par exemple c'est un pull en
laine mérinos et en poils de poster
c'est très légère très de vous forte et
c'est très chaud
contraint et forcé robert s'est
improvisé trappeur il capture en moyenne
1500 opossum chaque année
l'animal est ainsi devenu une source de
revenus pour la famille
pendant que son robinson couvre la forêt
en quête des plus belles peaux
quatrièmement fait tourner l'entreprise
familiale
là vous voyez je fabrique un couvre lit
pour deux personnes
je découpe les frais je les agences dans
l'ordre choisi
celui ci est prêt à être cousues
[Musique]
j'en fais trois ou quatre par an
j'achète et poireaux blair
alors vous faites du commerce en famille
oui c'est ça mais l'argent du produit
fini rentrer dans la même caisse
est ce cher l'opossum
sait rester un produit de luxe ça n'est
sans doute pas considérée comme la plus
belle fourrure mais c'est de la très
bonne qualité
l'opossum a toujours été utilisé pour ça
ici c'est une très belle fourrure
2800 $ néo-zélandais 1700 euros pour les
plus belles pièces
l'atelier de catherine tourne ainsi
depuis des années grâce au bouche à
oreille
seedorf le pilote de l'hélicoptère qui
achemine la précieuse marchandise en
ville quelquefois par an
chaque fin d'après midi robert a rendez
vous
c'est sans doute le plus beau moment de
la journée celui qu'il préfère l'heure
où le soleil met le plus en valeur sa
gorge river
j'ai toujours peint depuis que je vis
ici
c'était à loisir au début et quand
catherine m'a rejoint et on a eu les
enfants j'ai commencé à vendre mes
peintures et je suis devenu pas très
professionnel
depuis cinq ans ça sur à peu près la
moitié de nos revenus
ses toiles se négocie entre 1000 et 1500
euros
celle-ci s'envolera bientôt pour
l'australie la corde riverhin fait de
robert un peintre reconnu de la côte
ouest un artiste comblé
je suis tellement amoureux de cet
endroit je vise ici parce que c'est un
lieu incroyable
alors de peindre du mieux possible ce
beau
les gens en mettant mes peintures au mur
puisse avoir une fenêtre sur cette
nature cela
c'est un moyen pour moi de faire
partager la gauche ce que nous faisons
ici ce que nous sommes
c'est ce que je souhaite
on pourrait croire que vivre loin des
hommes de l'agitation des villes
encourage à d'oisiveté
mais la gorge river n'offre aucun répit
même à la plage robert a encore et
toujours de quoi s'occuper
[Musique]
je cherche des poux d'amour armes je
peux y passer des heures voire des
semaines
le poulamon un cadeau de la corderie
veulent un caillou une pierre verte
l'île du sud et en particulier la côte
ouest abrite les plus grands gisements
de jade de nouvelle zélande
les maoris s'en servaient de monnaie
d'échangé avec les colons
robert perpétue la tradition
tout naturellement
[Musique]
vous avez trouvé robert
c'est la pierre verte
on peut dire que j'ai gagné ma journée
un
combat au riz on l'appelle boudamous
c'est plus connus comme du jade
elles viennent des glaciers qui
l'arrachent à la montagne elle arrive de
là-haut et atterrissent dans la rivière
ou alors elles sont là sur la plage
depuis des années des années peut-être
milan
elles ont lentement tracer leur chemin
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un y trouve
est une pierre brute comme ça ça vaut
combien
c'est difficile de lui donner une valeur
mais pour un beau spécimen bien polis
comme celui-ci peut-être 400 dollars
certaines pierres comme celle là on les
garde brut
mais si je décide de la taille et je
peux probablement faire un petit dauphin
ou un oiseau
cette pierre on appelle ça le haras
c'est
la couleur verte est celle du coeur de
la forêt de la paix c'est le pouvoir
qu'on attribue à cette pierre
[Musique]
jamais les bouchons d'oreille un casque
et mon chat pour le podium
ça atténue le bruit et quand je
travaille sous la pluie en plus simple
qu'un choix
comme pour ses peintures
c'est la nature la gorge lui vole son
univers qui l'inspirent
robert sculpte dans le jade les êtres
avec lesquels il vit depuis 35 ans
j'adore faire des dauphins
je pense que c'est ce que je préfère
sculpté en fait
c'est une si belle créature
c'est pour moi un symbole de ce que
l'homme aimerait être
ils sont libres ils ont l'air de sourire
tout le temps
il semble vivre ensemble en harmonie en
famille
des créatures libre un peu comme pour
berlin
oui on peut dire que je suis libre et je
suis heureux comme ça
je sais que parfois on est tenté de
regarder en arrière
moi j'y tiens la médecine quand je suis
parti je pourrais être docteur
aujourd'hui ce serait bien aussi mais je
n'ai jamais pensé à partir et à
retrouver une vie conventionnelle je
vivrai ici aussi longtemps que possible
parce que cet endroit est incroyable
une vie à la gorge lui veut ce titre est
celui d'un livre qui a eu un certain
succès en nouvelle-zélande
l'auteur robert lang
son histoire aurait pu rester secrète
mais l'homme aime partager son paradis
du bout du monde
[Musique]